this is Jocko underground podcast number
41 with Echo Charles
sitting here across from me
I'm Dr willink uh so
there's a little something to talk about
the idea of of thinking I'm wrong
like if you and I are going to have a
conversation
and I go into the conversation thinking
Hmm I could be wrong
what does that do
I'll tell you something extremely
positive that happens and this is how I
go into conversations I go into
conversations thinking hey oh echo's got
a plan for doing something I've got a
plan for doing something I'm probably
wrong
Echoes ideas probably right so cool
let's have a conversation and he can
prove that he's right
and show me how he's right and I'll I'm
okay with being wrong so what does that
do it opens my mind
open Smart now does this mean I blindly
say yes echo's right and I'm wrong no no
no I might ask you some Earnest
questions but I'm not going to get
hostile about it
I'm not going to get get aggro about it
I'm gonna kind of uh you know
be okay
now where people might get concerned
about this is then you think oh well
if I'm going into a conversation
thinking uh uh I'm wrong
then I don't have any confidence
no I'm sorry as soon as he says
something I'm just going to shut down no
here's where there's here's we have to
here's we have to open your mind a
little bit
if you go in with an attitude of hey I
I'm I'm probably wrong
it actually increases your confidence
oddly enough because
it's almost like going into a
game or a grappling match where you know
you're gonna lose
now look you go in your you could have
let's say you were a 10 time well let's
say you were a 10-time world champion in
Jiu Jitsu and I was a purple belt you
are black belt 10-time world champion
and you and I were gonna scrap
I could go in like oh I'm gonna get beat
and that could hurt my confidence or I
could be like hey man this guy's a world
champion 10 times and he's a black belt
and I'm only a purple belt I'm gonna go
in there and try and learn some stuff
I'm gonna keep an open mind watch what
he does and I kind of have nothing to
lose so if I want to throw a move out
there I can do it and if he gets shut
down I get tapped out it's not that big
of a deal yeah
if you so so that's the attitude that
will make you
able to think and accept other ideas
more is to go in there with an attitude
not of like he's gonna destroy me and
I'm horrible but like hey I can go in
there take some risks listen learn some
moves pay attention and that's okay and
I'm not a loser because of it when you
see a
uh you know like someone steps up in
weight class Jeff Glover steps up in
weight class and goes up against a big
monster guy that's equivalent level so
the guy has a huge advantage and then
Jeff gets beat
do you go man what a loser
no no you freaking you give respect
because he rolled the dice and he
stepped in there and and he got beaten
it's no big deal
Jeff Glover does that in practice too
he'll like let you get a rear naked
choke
I've seen him let some random Purple
belt get a rear naked choke on him
and once it's sunk in hooks are in
full rear naked choke then you see Jeff
start to try and Escape
and I've seen him tap
after he let a guy get Hooks full rear
naked choke then starts to escape and he
gets tapped and he's like ah whatever
so it's not that big of a deal
if you can put your ego in check it's
not that big of a deal
so
thinking to yourself consciously until
you get in the habit of it think of
yourself like hey I might be wrong I'm
going to this conversation going into
this meeting I'm going to this planning
session I'm gonna have a discussion with
my wife about something
going into it and thinking yourself all
right I'm gonna be wrong and that's okay
is an awesome way to adjust your
attitude it's an awesome way to open
your mind and it's an awesome way to
move forward in life does it mean you
lack confidence no it doesn't
it means you're gonna win
because your your mind is open and
that's going to allow you to get there
yeah one of those easier said than done
kind of that's actually easier said than
done it's definitely easier said than
done it's such the heart one of the
hardest parts about it is seeing that
that it's an advantage yeah because you
know what people say is like when you go
into a room you got to say tell yourself
like I'm ready I'm gonna own that room
I'm I got I've gotta you know they do
the where you look in the mirror and you
like raise your hands and you go like hi
I am Victory or whatever right sure
that's what they tell you to say
okay but if you go in there and say hey
victory victory is coming out the best
idea from this group that's Victory okay
cool I'm gonna have an open mind I'm
gonna listen it's how you win
yeah
yeah that's what's hard to get there
yeah it's one of those like struggles
it's it's kind of like a big picture
versus small picture or a short term
versus long-term struggle where
um and especially if you if you go in
saying I could be wrong kind of a thing
you're already playing the long game
already so that and you know in life
that's everybody's struggle Because by
the way what are the chances that the
discussion that you and I are about to
have is the most important and impactful
and final discussion that you and I are
ever gonna have the chances are about
zero yeah but that's a big picture
perspective which that doesn't come
right like intuitively a lot of the time
think about it the big picture small
picture short term long term is your
whole life that's the the struggle in
every aspect of life like even
relationships freaking money Health what
you eat what you exercise you know
exercise like everything everything that
you do versus tactical exactly right
long term versus short term yep and so
um and that also goes big big picture
small picture so like if I say true if I
start which is a subtle difference
but if I'm like hey I could be wrong
you're you being wrong isn't that big of
a deal at the end of the day right
that's a big picture attitude me being
wrong when I say I'm right that is a big
deal it's a bigger deal yes and
depending on the size of your ego it
could be a huge huge deal exactly and
depending on the size of the other
person's ego it could be a huge deal
because they like that Victory they like
see you squirming in defeat yeah but why
would you box yourself into that corner
has very little impact in your life very
little impact yeah I mean how many
things are you debating in a day that
has a massive impact on your life yeah
not a lot I mean unless you're debating
with some world leader about something
yeah you could be debating whether you
make this investment which is a lot of
money for you yeah and if it's that much
money for you maybe you should back it
off a little bit so that is not a
massive risk but you still get some
upside in fact who shouldn't you really
go in thinking you might be wrong yeah
yeah it's one of those things man you
got to be careful yeah so just keep that
idea in mind it's it really I think
people are scared of it because they
think they're gonna come across as they
lack confidence what's more confident
what's more confident when I roll in the
room like hey I'm not 100 sure of this
idea but here's what I'm presenting or
like my idea is right bro you sound
paranoid already pointed no return right
there please don't do it yeah you just
pad your like you just up the stakes
it's almost like social Stakes kind of
or ego statement but you just up the
stakes all the way to like an
unreasonable degree when you're when you
come with that kind of conviction don't
do it now when you go I could be wrong
brother Stakes are very limited if kind
of non-existent
mind is open exactly right the mind is
open check all right let's get to some q
a what do we got first question Jaco I'm
a police officer and signed up for BJJ
because I know the quarterly Refreshers
we get aren't anywhere near the amount
of training I need
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it cost eight
dollars and 18 cents a month and if you
can't afford to support us we can still
support you just email assistance Jocko
underground.com and we'll get you taken
care of until then we
mobilized
Underground